Nói tìm hồi chế bên thống nhất là áp dụng 2 mồ hình sát nhập như sao?
Mồ hình một chường mồ cấp học quy mù lớn, mọi trúc đầm giá sức ứng xe, có khóa cấp và nheu
Cơ cầu dân xe, vô mồ tiểu chờ, cấp có hiểu chờ, mồ tù mộ phận hành chiến dân xe, kể toán tù của ý văn thư, rung trông.
Đi theo tình hình thực tế về quy mồ lớp, hi học xe, khóa cấp địa lý đến chường trình, mồ chỉ mỗi phân hiểu có một phó hiểu chường vụ trách trong tập số địa bình trế được ra, để bảo đảm trở lận ra rồi.
Mồ hình 2 trường vô thông nhiều cấp học quy mồ lớn, mồ hình này được thực hiện tại một điểm, hòa cấp địa điểm khác nhau, cậu chung vô mồ trường trình có các định trường với nhiều cấp học, cơ cầu dân xe, vô mồ hiểu chờ, cơ cầu phó hiểu chờ, mồ phận hành chiến dân xe, kể toán tù của ý văn thư, rung trông.
Đi theo tình hình thực tế về các học quy mồ lớp, hiểu chờ phó khóa cấp địa lý đến chường trình, mồ chỉ mỗi phân hiểu có một phó hiểu chờ vụ trách trong tập số địa bình trế được ra, để bảo đảm trở lận ra rồi.
Đối với các cơ cơ xử giáo dụng mồ nòn phó thông trực thuộc bị bán nhân dân phương xã và đặc khu, mồ đình về hành chiến cấp xã và phải bảo đảm tối thiệu, bất cơ xử giáo dụng mồ nòn, mồ thông cộng ứng, lũ cấp kiểu học, chung hà cơ xử bảo đảm linh hoạt.
Theo lộ trình, phù hợp với tình hình thực tế để phương trong tập tế khu vực đu tiền mồ hình chiều phó thông cộng hiểu cấp học tại các khu vực dân cư thiêu thất hoặc nơi có điều kiện đi lại khó khăn.
Mình với các đơn vị trình tộc xử giáo dụng và đặc tạo tìm xó xếc các đơn vị theo lại hình phù hợp với các quy định hành.
Tây bố chỉ mình hiện có mạng lối cơ xử giáo dụng mồ nòn phó thông giáo dụng thường xây lớn nước cả nước.
Với hành những một chẳng tảm đám cơ xử giáo dụng mồ nòn, tuy nhiên tình dầu trường còn có quy mồ nhỏ mà mạnh mồn.
Chưa phù hợp về không dàn phát triển và quy mồ dân số của đơn vị hành chiến.